hello there reject nation
I'm Greg album time John Humphrey what
would a real rejects month be without
checking out a Tyrone Magnus video this
is a topper warranty request from our
patreon page from peat dawn here's
exactly what he said I just realized
Tyrone's birthday just passed according
to Google so why not this video The
Rock's most electrifying fan sends a
message to John Cena to remember how far
he came in his life tyro Magnus can
always came on my face for as long as he
wants 1 million sperms I've never seen
this video super old years I think two
things only number one to see the Phenom
The Undertaker and number 2 just see the
great one the people's chant the chosen
one John Cena
1 2 3
you see John Cena discovered a miracle
happens he's hoping in the boom and the
rocks to spinebuster on it takes his
throne to the people top it sitting rock
in Section F 12 row K c11 I'll catch it
I'll jump into the ring
[Music]
oh I was so into that nice it's like
watching the rock be brought to life I
know I'm sitting here thinking why
hasn't Tyrone Magnus enjoyed his
successful career as a wrestler I mean
that he's got that he's got the buffness
he's got the charisma man like I I for a
second I forgot we were watching Tyrone
I was like yeah dude this guy's gonna
get in the ring destroy Johnson see it's
Tyra happiest era - I've seen his Rock
impression before very small doses he
really really narrowed the stances for
March 16 2012 you need to do more videos
like this dude dude please just do dude
the rockery is like that give me a whole
separate aspect of your channel just the
rock reacts to everything
what is this Hopf comment here from a
Nia star I love watching people's first
video so inspirational
oh wow this needs more views this needs
a lot more views dude let's blow this
video up I want 1 million likes on that
like button this one video alone for
promo is better than what I hear all the
WWE has turned into recently yourself
because that Marky Mark and the Funky
bones crap is what made you this is what
you need to save you actually got a
whole like hour-long breakdown of double
UWE starting from the 90s to today oh
just the other day so this was expert
yeah I'm an expert now now I know
everything there is to know about
wrestling it seems to me like you're the
expert Marc and Tyrone you brought it
all the life here you have come a long
way this is your shitty studio apartment
from when I would first chat with you
down in New Jersey now you got a nice
ass home
you got a fine-ass female by your side
now come a long way yeah barely any subs
then now you have like over subscribers
Oh a million and a half you're killing
it dude you've come so far come so far
I'm proud of you buddy
I remember when we first talked you were
still working a job and doing YouTube
and then eventually you quit it took my
advice because you took my advice now
you are where you're at dude you
basically built the Tyrone Magnus
channel I mean the large part basically
oh all your success to me yeah and you
and javi Kawai both owe me a lot yeah I
think it's kind of weird that you don't
acknowledge that more often you know the
way to pay it back is by literally
giving hard-earned cash directly to my
bank account yeah I'll send you a
message and text my routing number and
account number to my Wells Fargo Bank
and very simply I expect a few thousand
dollars to be directly transferred into
my banking account as soon as possible I
hope you understand this do you think
Tyrone ever does like romantic roleplay
as the rock I think the rock is romantic
roleplay as Tyrone I'm sorry that's what
I meant - you should play the rock in
his biopic you'll be way too old I still
think you should do it self produce it
just start now uh oh this is fun thanks
for taking us back to this point in time
peat dawn yeah man Pete I had a time of
filming this I haven't replied to your
last message he said to me Greg since
you're also a writer I have a question
for you I just got done writing like
Episode one of five parts for a volume
my book how many times should I reread
it and edit it before I started looking
for test readers also how many people
should I let test read it well
considering I've written many books I
had tester at all I've test read all
them into large focus groups thousands
of people before I've ever released them
they're all available for $30.99 on
Amazon that's three thousand $99 per
volume on Amazon 45 page books that I
hope you can go get today by the way let
me see here
first question and how many times should
I reread it well if you've only written
an episode one of five I would reread it
at least 10 times edit down to make it
as short as possible people don't like
description we like things to be
straight forward straight to the point
and then immediately have as many people
as you can test read it I don't suggest
copywriting it and I don't suggest you
know making sure there's any legalities
to deal with or hand I would just give
it away
skip it away to as many people as
possible let as many people as you want
read it put it online first see how
people respond and then sell it
publish it one word at a time just on
your Twitter account and just keep it
going forever and never it's not about
the money you know it's about the art
meet oh my god and if you're truly
trying to make arts yes just just put it
out there in the hands of the people see
if your art is worth reading first let
the episode one be for free and then
other people can buy two three four and
five it's about art okay yeah that's why
you can buy my art for three thousand
ninety nine dollars on amazon.com and
I'll strip for you for change
[Music]